hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw there is
literally nothing coming out this week
well not literally
there's figuratively nothing coming out
this week what I wasn't even gonna do an
episode because nothing coming out but I
had all this makeup on from another
video that I filmed today and I figured
I mean it takes me a half hour to do
this might as well get some music so
here we are looking fabulous and bored
to tears by the boy who would be king or
should be king I don't know could be
king the boy who turned to be king the
boy who would could should be king is
about a young man named Alex who finds
the legendary sword Excalibur
that's stored sword Excalibur and unites
some of his enemies to become friends
and actually Knights them and then has
to face off with the evil enchantress
Morgana and team up with students and
and it's it's it's a cute idea can I
Knight you sir Ike warrior of the
household Vanquisher of kibbles I feel
like I've said this in the last two or
three tamra just saw episodes it's a
killer idea and it's just missing
something I don't know there was
something so lackluster about it and
there were such moments of boredom
throughout and yet at the end I still I
enjoyed myself for sure it was such a
fun idea and like if I would have seen
this as a ten-year-old hell yeah and
definitely this wasn't like made for me
it's definitely definitely geared at a
younger audience but that being said oh
I'm sorry was i boring you
goodbye but that being said I don't know
I think it was the acting which sucks to
say cuz they're kids
and they did a great job but I think the
direction for the acting or maybe it was
the score something about it felt really
lackluster
like it felt boring even though
fantastical things are happening on
screen
it felt black
Lester is Lord I want to use a couple
things that really worked for it the
beginning animation was awesome it
starts out with this killer animation
telling you the story of Merlin and the
knights of the round table and the sword
in the stone and it was awesome it was
also creepy as hell when you saw Morgana
Arthur's half-sister and the villains in
this movie are so creepy and cool
Morgana literally is a dragon it's the
coolest thing and I was very impressed
that they took it that far in that I
think that the epicness they were going
for wasn't like cut down because it's a
kid's film I think it was just they
missed a mark somewhere because the
villains ruled another amazing thing was
the casting of young and of course old
Merlin young Merlin was killer
Angus I'm really something read he it's
amazing he's been in a few things that
I've not seen no surprise there but I
just can't wait to see where his his
acting career goes because he was so
delightful to watch he had to do this
thing
Merlin's magic came from this weird like
like hand gesture dude thing that he was
doing and anyone else would have made it
look like absolute horse crap he looked
so cool doing it and every time it made
me smile it was it was a weird choice to
make direct orally for like that to be
the or you know it's in the script
probably but it was on and he really
made it work if he didn't sell it like
he did that would have been so weird cuz
it also happened a lot so that was fun
I really enjoyed him I thought he was
great and then of course Patrick Stewart
as old Merlin a done is gonna be amazing
he was a delight and they played each
other really really well it seems like
they were the young and old version of
each other and it switches out between
the movie and he just had a blast with
Merlin not the first time I said that
and it won't be the last
what I really learned from this is that
Patrick Stewart can save pretty much any
movie No well yeah there's some really
clever things
that they use telling the story with a
modern twist I think that that was
really well done and could have been
super cheesy it also could have like
aged it if they used too much like
technology I say that a lot on this show
that I think that technology especially
like the internet and like iPhones
really ageism movie for me for some
reason even though we're like in the
midst of it I don't know why it always
just rubs me so wrong this movie did a
really good job of taking new things and
and putting them into this really old
and beloved story I think it also did a
good job of that I don't know how to say
this without sounding dumb which let's
be honest total tamra mood but it was
very British in that like I feel like I
don't know I think if it was set in
America it maybe would have been worse
in that aspect
at one point Alex's friend Bettis I
think his name is he learns this
duplication thing for a Merlin and does
it and then they go to this arcade and
he does it on one of the machines it
gets a bunch of coins from it so they
can buy armor with like a bunch of coins
and it was a really clever and it was
super fun and light-hearted and it was
just new enough like the arcade was just
new enough the biggest battle at the end
happens during a solar eclipse and they
all have the little glasses on and all
this armor and it's really cute it's so
they do some really clever things
there's a couple really cool scenes
where the CGI looks really good there's
one scene where they're fighting these
trees Merlin is trying to train them I
would say there's a lot less training
then would really be needed to defeat
Morgana but you know they do a good job
of kind of splicing it in when they
can't so they're fighting these trees
the trees look awesome it's really
clever the trees are kind of helping
them out it's really cool
again the villains are awesome they're
super creepy there's these guys riding
horses and they're bony and they're like
decaying and they're on fire and it's
super cool it's also cool that the level
to defeat them isn't too hard like
they're just a bunch of bones so if you
basically hit them they fall just kind
of fun it's kind of video game II I'm
also playing Skyrim right now on switch
got for Christmas and so dragons are
fresh on my mind and that Morgan turns
the to a dragon is pretty safe is it a
dragon is it a dragon or a with a weave
Vern we Vern
dragons have four legs while we Verne's
only have two oh it was a we Vern I
actually don't know that she was either
of these things she claims to be a
dragon but she she looks more like a
flying snake which again scary it's a
flying danger noodle and then there were
also some not-so-great portions of the
movie and I really think it just comes
down to my word of the day lackluster
the bullies are effective and they're
cute and pretty overall Bland's but
overall just the acting in general other
than mini Merlin and not mini Merlin was
it's pretty lackluster and I think that
might be a direction thing again I keep
coming back to score too when there was
really epic moments you just felt kind
of like okay I don't feel any stakes
right now like the very final fight is
really cool and super well choreographed
and it looked great but the mute there
was nothing like telling me that I
should feel something and I don't have
to be the music now that I'm thinking
back on it
cuz it left no lasting impact the friend
Bettis again I forget his name I think
it's Vettes he says everything like a
sad prince everything is so but I you
know I imagine they must have directed
him to do this it's a lot of times he's
like oh I'm the Sam Weiss to your
frontal Baggins
it's like okay well then that's what
he's playing up obviously okay I get I
see but you still sound like a sad
little prince
I know it's just next I'm not really
crying thanks but he's worried actor I
know it's unbelievable all of the
attempts at comedy were crazy bad and I
realized but you said that after I just
did that whole thing but they were bad
with the characters I realized what they
they're trying to make them approachable
they're trying to make them anyone like
like when they make characters like
Bella Swan and you're like do you have
any qualities at all do you identify
with anything in that vanilla mind of
yours at all and it's because the author
wanted people to put themselves into the
character and then it's kind of the same
thing here they wanted Alex to be this
every guy who could just anyone could
put themselves into this character but
it didn't carry the story I don't think
overall I had a really good time with
the imagination of this movie and while
it's missing some elements that would
make it a little more exciting I would
still recommend this I'm gonna try out a
new rating system because I'd like to
bring over the hair flips from Tamara's
never seen into Tamra just saw so out of
10 I would give this
six hair flips probably should have done
my hair differently for the grand reveal
of the the hair flips and Tamra just hop
but anyways we'll tackle it next week
thank you so much for watching and as
the movie said a land is only as good as
its leaders
[Music]